we're acknowledging and playing with the
cultural landscape
you know Monica Ruis is the actress that
was in the Palatine ad was in a
situation that I've been in many times
before when you do you have a piece of
content you're an actor you put it out
there and it doesn't quite work and you
feel a little alienated and stuff sided
tremendous empathy for her in that
moment on Wednesday December 4th Ryan
got wind of a viral video involving a
woman on a peloton bike the internet
backlash was quick and severe with many
calling it sexist and out of touch first
riding the wrist but excited let's do
this five days in a row how much this
would change me thank you
by Friday Ryan's gin company found the
starring actress Monica ruas and filmed
a brand new ad poking fun at all the
backlash and released it that night
you're safe here
to new beginnings to new beginning
no it's gonna be a fun night doing the
Aviation Jeanette Search gave her some
authorship over some of this
conversation which I loved and she's
she's the best she's really funny really
smart she's handling already Monica will
do her first sit-down interview with The
Today Show tomorrow but this weekend she
released a statement saying although I'm
an actress I'm not quite comfortable
being in the spotlight and I'm terrible
on social media so to say I was shocked
and overwhelmed by the attention this
week especially the negative is an
understatement
the company behind the original peloton
ad says they are disappointed the
commercial has been misinterpreted as
sexist as for the man fronting it all
well he's now been dubbed the peloton
husband Shawn hunter a Vancouver
elementary teacher told Global News BC
he's even received hurtful messages
online people started using harsh words
sexist misogynist a symbol of the
patriarchy and I and I whoa this is
these are harsh things that are not
associated with my character and not
associated with me
in any way I want people to remember the
positive elements that happened in the
commercial we're promoting Fitness we're
promoting personal health
[Music]